en plateau donc en direct 18h15 si vous
venez de nous rejoindre pour la suite du
7-8 nous sommes le 4 avril à nous avons
à présent une page économie avec claire
comme il est bon soir claire bonsoir ils
sont collégiens et déjà la tête d'une
entreprise 15 élèves du collège
descartes de fontenay-le-fleury ont créé
leur société body b c'est une initiative
assez original qui permet à ces jeunes
de découvrir le monde du travail
pour nous en parler nous recevons louise
marie de fer bonjour ou collégial mais
aussi directrice communications et
marketing de body b à vos côtés votre
professeur célia en soit vous épauler
les élèves avec une autre de vos
collègues balade en voiture tout à fait
et enfin le parrain de body v stéphane
cana sony donc qui est aussi directeur
d'un supermarché à voir si tout sauf le
body b ce qu'on appelle une mini
entreprise
c'est la première fois que cette
initiative est mise en place dans votre
collège descartes
mais ce n'est pas la première du genre
dans le département où en france c'est
un concept qui existe depuis les années
20 aux états unis et c'est l'association
agir pour entreprendre qui a laissé cha
lancé par dans cette démarche dans
l'hexagone donc célia on saute vous
pouvez nous dire un mot peut-être sur ce
concept
oui tout à fait donc en fait c'est grâce
à madame richmond et madame viel qui ont
eu un coup de coeur en fête pour le
projet dp3 qu'elles ont décidé l'année
dernière d'aller voir tout simplement
des associations qui était apte à nous
suivre dans cette démarche au collège
descartes à fontenay le fleury et donc
elles ont assisté à un concours régional
au championnat régional des mini
entrepreneurs et elles ont eu un coup de
coeur parce qu'elle nous trouve l idée
absolument fantastique et donc elles ont
contacté ep à entreprendre pour rentrer
à prendre qui est une association qui en
fait nous épaule et nous aide pour
mettre en place la longue
disent que les quinze élèves vont crier
tout simplement
et elles ont donc demandé aux élèves de
4e de fin de quatrième qui allait
rentrer en troisième de faire un cv une
lettre de motivation pour voilà pour
rentrer dans la dp3 et seuls ceux qui
ont été réellement motivés ont été
sélectionnés tout simplement vous a mis
en place un cours hebdomadaire de 3
heures par semaine exactement qui a lieu
le mercredi matin
tous les mercredis matins avec madame
vielle cela montre les 15 des neiges
voilà exactement tout à fait alors ne me
louise tué une de ces mini entrepreneurs
oui pour commencer tu peux nous dire
peut-être un mot sur sur cette société
alors body b en fait elle fabrique elle
elle a créé des bodys personnalisée
c'est à dire c'est ce sont souvent des
bodys où il ya des phrases humoristique
il y en a quatre adorables quand je veux
fonctionne sans pile qui s'est levé
cette semaine maman une barre et papa
plusieurs bars et job à plein temps et
on voit là les plus mortelles voilà leur
taille en trois je croise pourquoi des
bodys finalement parce qu'en fait on a
fait une étude de marché on avait
plusieurs idées et il s'est révélé que
moody's ce qui est une bonne idée
on voit là et le nom body body b alors
motivé en fait c'est de grand baie ça
fait rappeler à bb et comme c'est des
bodys ben vous dit forcément
alors stéphane canet sony vous êtes donc
le parrain de body b quel est votre rôle
en fait comme moi j'ai été contacté en
qualité de parrain pour ramener j'allais
dire l'expérience de l'entreprise
et puis permettent d'échanger sur mon
expérience avec avec les élèves et les
professeurs et ce sont les élèves qui
vous ont contacté ce sont les
professeurs et madame richement
particulier voilà qui nous barrent
l'entrée principale qui m'a proposé de
parrainer la mini-entreprise effet quel
regard vous portez sur le travail qui a
été mené
entendu étude de marché on parle du
vraiment ma le jargon des mondes et
entreprises un qui est utilisée est bien
maîtrisé ce sont des millions et tout le
regard vous portez son travail qu'ils
ont menées moi je suis en rien et c'est
un regard très intéressant parce que je
suis arrivé dès le début du projet
j'avais affaire à des élèves est en
effet comme ça vient d'être dit
aujourd'hui j'ai en face des mini
entrepreneurs qui sont rentrés dans le
rôle j'ai dire presque même
hiérarchiques de l'entreprise et qui
sont imprégnés aujourd'hui de la culture
de leur entreprise qu'ils ont créé hélas
l'étape d'après ça va être la
commercialisation
donc voilà on qu'on a des mini
entrepreneurs aujourd'hui face à nous
avant de poursuivre je vous propose de
regarder le reportage que nous avons
réalisés sur body b nous sommes rendus
au collège descartes où nous avons
retrouvé les ministres entrepreneurs en
plein travail c'est un moment de la vie
de cette entreprise un sujet réalisé
avec patrick jacques de dixmude dans
cette salle de classe on assiste à un
cours pas comme les autres ici ces
jeunes ne sont plus de simples élèves de
troisième il se transforme en dirigeant
d'entreprise leur société body b ou
vendée bocci de tailles différentes
il ya trois mois six mois et neuf mois
personnalisez donc avec des phrases
fonctionne sans pile par exemple en tout
quinze élèves du collège descartes de
fontenay-le-fleury volontaire est
sélectionné en début d'année sur lettre
de motivation cette mini entreprise et
encadrés par deux professeurs et un par
un le directeur d'un supermarché
une fois qu'ils sont partis sur leurs
idées body et cetera là en fait on leur
a fait passer des entretiens d'embauché
avec monsieur canaux signé notre parrain
est donc là c'est monsieur canaux
cynique a décidé en fonction des
compétences de chacun et en fonction du
poste pour lequel il avait postulé qui
ferait quoi devant cet ordinateur on
s'occupe de la comptabilité 70
investisseurs ont permis à cette
entreprise de se financer via des
avances remboursables vendus 4
une partie d'entre eux sera présente à
l'assemblée générale de l'entreprise au
clavier on s'active car tout doit être
au point pour cette réunion les statuts
de l'entreprise notamment à droite
ce groupe est chargé du design des body
aujourd'hui il finalise le logo dernière
étape avant la fabrication c'est le
comble pas mal du tout mais il faut
aussi penser à la vente
les jeunes tiendront un stand le 29 mai
dans le supermarché de leurs parrains et
marie et ses collègues ont une idée pour
booster leurs ventes là en fait on a
préparé un dialogue que j'ai faire
téléphone tout à l'heure pour appeler un
clown
je des médecins le rire des médecins
pardon et donc on va leur demander de
venir à notre stand
direction le bureau de la principale
pour téléphoner à cette association body
b compte de leur reverser 15 % de leurs
ventes
première démarche commerciale pour marie
alors elle est un peu stressé
tu peux t'asseoir et voilà tout
l'angoissent qui avec les médicaments
les opérations cela semble bien parti
pour body b cette entreprise n'est pas
la seule du genre
l'association agir pour entreprendre
inciter les établissements scolaires à
se lancer dans l'aventuré cette année
dans les yvelines 12 mini entreprises
ont vu le joueur alors finalement cette
fameuse démarches auprès de cette
association elle a fonctionné
ils seront présents au stand alors les
clowns eux-mêmes peuvent venir mais les
bénévoles et donc l on réfléchisse en
fait sur comment mettre en place le
stand il monsieur cannes aussi nous a
donné des conseils notamment sur les
banderoles donc il y aura la tête de mon
fiston sur les banderoles on pourra
tirer parce que c'est le plus beau et
voulait vraiment on a mis donc d'aider
des slogans bonne idée
la mère des bébés est beau et donc on a
mis mon fils en train de rire aux éclats
donc on voulait voilà proposé ça
monsieur canaux 6 me pour faire les
banderoles autour du stand à souastre
actifs à côté du rayon puériculture pour
que les gens les clients viennent le 29
mai au leclerc de bois d'arcy parce que
ça va mais ce cadeau ceni dont vous les
aider par exemple à travers sa gestion
c'est eux qui ont fait la démarche
oui exactement là j'allais dire après
comment on est dans une mini entreprise
ça devient pour le magasin fournisseur
j'allais dire normal si on peut dire ça
comme ça sur lequel moi j'apporte tous
mes conseils et on va enfin mettre à
disposition un espace dans le magasin
commerçants pour essayer ben là je suis
impliqué de faire les meilleurs et ça
leur apporte quoi véritablement alors
parce qu'on voit ça marche comme une
entreprise c'est très sérieux on
mettrait bien le jargon il ya toutes les
étapes qui sont pensés et réfléchis
ça leur apporte quoi au final il va
écouter ça leur apporte de la maturité
ça leur apporte une expérience où enfin
on les sort de leur rôle d'élève
c'est à dire savoir d'accord sur de
l'argent on leur fait confiance moi je
leur donne mon portable s'ils ont un
coup de fil à fait à passer des choses
évidemment qu'on ne fait pas dans le
collège parce qu'il ya un règlement
intérieur et c'est tout à fait normal
mais au sein de la dp3 c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est le côté on va dire on
à faire un élève limite on est vraiment
d'égal à égal on réfléchit ensemble aux
solutions on se passe nos coordonnées
ils connaissent mon prénom ils ont mon
mail enfin voila c'est avec madame
viennent donc vraiment on est comment
dire ya une complicité qui s'installe
mais samedi il fallait piste avec le
parcours plus classique au grâce une
fois que cela est terminé on vous fait
la différence
via le monde professionnel de vos 10 b
on est d une mini entrepreneurs et
ah le collège où c'est plus la même
exactement et madame dit elle est
professeure principale des troisièmes
d'eux il ya les as en cours donc c'est
vrai qu'on pourrait croire au début
qu'il ya une confusion mais en fait non
comme les rôles les élèves de faire
exactement la différence entre ce qu'on
est à la dp3 est ce qu'on est en tant
que professeur de français dès cet été
franchement les limites sont bien
établis parce que du coup au delà au
niveau de votre matière le français il
ya aucun lien et basse bah si justement
moi j'ai la chance d'avoir une matière
qui a un lien
évidemment avec eux je rédigeais encore
mercredi le rapport d'activités avec
lara donc c'est vrai ils ont besoin d'un
petit coup de pouce à avec accent est
derrière donc j'ai un peu derrière en
train de de faire en sorte que les que
les on va dire que les fautes
n'apparaissent pas et puis surtout sur
la façon de s'exprimer
mais madame vielle en fait assure aussi
ce rôle très bien passée mais il est
très forte en français et aussi elle
gère beaucoup mieux les calculs que moi
donc tout ce qui a été grand elle est
professeur à la dette des états et
émacié graphique elle agirait
complètement donc il ya complémentarité
entre nous deux entre nous deux matières
entre nos deux caractères quand je ne
sais pas les élèves leur sont tous voilà
en se disant voilà on se sent bien et on
a l'impression que cette complicité en
fait apporte quelque chose de plus à la
dp3 alors justement ça a bien avancé
vous en êtes vous là actuellement ça y
est alors lancé oui oui elle est au
niveau des vous dis oui
les body il manque plus qu'à les faire
imprimer et normalement le 29 mai on
pourra faire la vente sans souci voilà
dans le clair de boîtes à nice
alors donc ce qui était intéressant
c'est que vous avez chacun ou que votre
rôle vous avez passé même des entretiens
voilà pour les vrais oui bienvenue
avec mais on devait être très bien placé
c'est passé justement
oui c'était me semble qu'il ait passé en
france c'est quoi ça s'est bien passé
bon moi j'ai un tort peut-être mais une
qualité c'est d'être un peu exigeant
donc en effet bondi de la façon
pédagogique j'ai essayé aussi d'orienter
les élèves sur voilà les choses qu'on
doit faire devant un recruteur et
malheureusement ce qu'on doit pas faire
voilà pour que j'allais dire dès
aujourd'hui puisse corriger ça faisait
roulent ce qu'il ya la présentation mais
il ya aussi la tenue à la façon de de
parler donc non ça s'est très bien passé
pour nous pour l'ensemble et pour
mademoiselle en particulier mais pour
l'ensemble ça s'est très bien passé et
je trouve que pour eux ça ça leur a mis
une pression mais très constructif parce
que là je pense que à ce moment là au
moment de l'entretien
ils ont perçu la responsabilité qu'il
prenait dans la mignonne et vaniteux
suite dans le bain finalement exactement
monsieur k nothing federer des
réajustements par rapport aux postes
pour lesquels les élèves postuler c'est
à dire que en effet il y en a qui
postulait pour par exemple directeur
commercial et finalement il s'avérait
que le directeur commercial qui se
présentaient n'était pas assez vif assez
réactif donc il a proposé des échanges
entre les services
par exemple on la nie pas plutôt aux
services administratifs est quelqu'un
qui était plus pétillant plus enfin
voilà qui argumentent et mieux était au
service commercial
donc on a qu'on a suivi ses conseils on
parle donc de ces minier entrepreneurs
au cours de cette page est qu on va
continuer à en parler juste la parole
aux saint quentinois pour l'instant la
jeunesse est-elle synonyme de
crédibilité pour créer son entreprise
c'est la question du jour que nous vous
avons posé bon bah pourquoi pas il n'y a
pas de raison à partir du moment une
idée est solide et qu'il ya des gens qui
ont la volonté de fer il n'y a pas de
raison que ça fonctionne pas c'est
crédible en effet ce qui sont épaulés
c'est sale et la question
ça peut leur montrer en effet le meut le
marché du travail ce que ça peut-être
oui ça peut être intéressant
va pour des enfants de 5e ça me paraît à
moitié crédible il faut qu'il soit déjà
bien encadré mais c'est une bonne
expérience pour eux de savoir comment se
crée une entreprise pour eux dans
l'avenir s'ils sont ils sont jeunes ils
sont pas enfin à mon avis sont pas dans
la vie a qui savent pas de quoi ils
parlent
les avis sont partagés on a entendu
est ce que la jeunesse c'est un atout
pour créer son entreprise justement je
pense que ça permet oui en effet deux
parades certitude donc c'est là où on
est né de grandes idées mais lorsque ce
qui est amusant c'est finalement vous
avez travaillé avec d'autres collégiens
vous avez comme sous-traitant une autre
mini entreprise
oui nous en dire un mot alors on a
visité un justement notre collège où il
faisait des flocages délicat justement
est assez intéressant pour nous pour
donc on va aller voir chez eux pour
qu'ils nous floch et voilà il avait déjà
qui travaillent avec des jalles des
merengues il donc on leur fait aussi un
petit peu de publicité basse et le ils
ont leurs emplettes leur entreprise de
flocage et donc on peut les contacter il
floch pour des associations pour des
tabliers de cuisine pour des sacs pour
des tee-shirts donc c'est vrai que ben e
ils nous font aller body et donc c'est
vrai que c'est une db6 nous découverte
professionnelle 6 heures à repousser
découverte professionnelle 3 heures et
voilà et c'est là qu'il ya eu un lien
qui s'est fait et la rencontre des
collégiens entre eux elle a quand même
été aussi très bénéfique à la fin de
l'année scolaire il ya une suite ou
l'entreprise ferme et ben l'entreprise
est le ferment pour laisser place en
septembre à une autre mini entreprise
avec des 4e qui vont passer en troisième
toujours avec ce principe de lettre de
motivation et cv et donc madame biel et
moi on repart sur le projet l'année
prochaine pour recréer complètement
autre chose parce que ça nous
intéresserait quand même de créer autre
chose que des body on va essayer de
pousser les élèves vont parce que si on
tourne autour de la même idée c'est un
peu lassant
alors c'est vrai qu'on va repartir sur
valider en septembre 2013 il ya quand
même un concours
quand on est
là vous y participer pendant oui on va y
participer
donc c'est un concours en fait entre eux
et les mini entrepreneurs de la région
sava etre département région après ça va
être ça va jusqu'à nationale oui c'est
le mercredi 22 mai donc il ya cinq
élèves qui vont présenter justement
notre mini entreprises audio vous avez
présenté votre entreprise vous avez
aussi certains réalisent d une pub quand
tu es directrice communications gsm
evans enterrant drôle ça allait aussi si
les banderoles tchibanga excusez moi oui
on est en train de regarder justement
pour les banderoles pour pour attirer à
l'arrière les attirer l'oeil
voilà deux secondes face à toussaint
plusieurs appels à date un rythme fou
mais la note de vente dans votre
hypermarché à bois d'arcy
voilà merci à tous les trois ans arrive
à bien suivre la page écho dans quelques
instants on fait juste une pause avec
une actualité du jour et ses parents à
plaisir dans le quartier du val hibou
qui ont décidé d'organiser des
patrouilles pour lutter contre les
squatteurs les jeunes du quartier qui
squattent ils veulent mettre fin aux
incivilités reportages sur des images a
signé patrick jacques de dixmude
20h locale de l'association mieux vivre
ovalie boua plaisir comme souvent des
résidents se réunissent une vingtaine
ils échangent autour d'un café avant de
dresser un plan d'action pour le soir
messieurs bonsoir merci de votre pensée
ou fort ce soir c'est je vous remercie
quand même voilà on va continuer notre
travail notre médiation
vous savez comme ce soir on est pas on
n'est pas atteint les temps on est prêt
la police n'a aucun information
juridique où il a des parents pour une
grand parents pour faire veiller sur
notre quartier le quartier en train de
dégrader on a besoin de veiller sur nous
car si les parents depuis plusieurs mois
avec les moyens du bord ils chassent les
incivilités commises le plus souvent par
des squatteurs c'est des jeunes de
quartiers comme mon fils comme les
enfoncer des jeunes ont le part
gentiment mais sont vraiment il est
quotidiennement ya pas de problème le
but foot pas dégrader le quartier parce
que ça coûte trop cher on est en crise
en ce moment les gens ils ont du mal à
payer leur loyer
si vous voulez rajouter encore de doses
de dégradation a payé c'est un peu ce
soir là quelques jeunes avec eux autour
de la table et un message parfois encore
difficile à faire face et nous n'a pas
d'activité il fait froid dehors ont vu
dans les temps du match mais voilà nous
après l'école qu'on sort de l'école
l'ont fait comme l'ont fait nos devoirs
en soirée aquarelle est rien on constate
chez privé c'est par petits groupes de 4
à 6 personnes que ces patrouilleurs
évolué de halls d'immeuble en hall
d'immeuble quelques mètres à peine et
première halte ou alors on constate ce
vais traiter pas cassé hier
aujourd'hui il est classé voit que ça
c'est mauvais ça fait 300 350 euros ça
ne coûte nos les parents l'inspection se
poursuit dans l'immeuble étage par étage
pas de nouvelle dégradation ce bâtiment
attend d'être rénové dans les prochains
mois ces patrouilles c'est aussi
l'occasion de rencontrer les jeunes un
peu plus loin un échange s'engage avec
deux d'entre eux l'action des locataires
est saluée mais les mêmes revendications
ressurgit
pas de lieu pour se rencontrer mais
aussi pas d'emploi ou si on est déçu
rien comme tout le monde on mange on vit
on dort pareil maintenant la seule
différence c'est l'emploi l'emploi et
puis la vie sociale où on vit exactement
nous on n'est pas des méchants on
accueille tout le monde
22h30 fin de la ronde
bilan de la soirée et quelques vitres
cassées et quelques tags un travail qui
semble porter ses fruits
les dégradations seront signalés au
bailleur social
mais ces patrouilleurs tiens à le
préciser pas question de se substituer
aux forces de l'ordre pour nous la
police est très important il faut qu'il
vient prochaine étape obtenir le statut
de correspondants de nuit délivrée par
les pouvoirs publics
ce serait une reconnaissance mais aussi
l'assurance d'obtenir des moyens
supplémentaires préfecture et
municipalités doivent se prononcer ce
système est déjà en place à mon plat
jockey